[Music]
so if you saw the show last night you
saw that dr mark siegel asked the
president about the
cognitive ability test white house
physicians have given him
and amazingly the president was happy to
talk about details here's part of it
it was 30 or 35 questions the first
questions are very easy
the last questions are much more
difficult
like a memory question it's like you'll
go
person woman man
camera tv
so they say could you repeat that so i
said yeah
so it's person woman man
camera tv okay that's very good
so guess who else was watching that
the weight lifter over on cnn
and his buddy don lemon so
the weightlifter for the governor's
brother decided to administer the test
the president
has taken to international tv star don
lemon and here's what happened next
when do you take that that looks like
something for middle school well
you take that when usually listen i'm
not a doctor and i'm going to let dr
reiner explain it in a little bit
yeah but usually when there is some
issue of some concern about
um you know your cognitive abilities
oh what were the animal shapes uh well
it's a lion
a hippo and a camel isn't that a rhino
in the middle or i know
you don't even know a hippo you've got
no acuity son
you've got you're looking at it
backwards i'm looking at it backwards
what does it mean if you don't know an
elephant from a rhino an elephant
what does it mean if you don't know a
rhino from an elephant
well you may not be a physician but i
think you know what it means
it means low acuity and that's not a
surprise in the case of don lamont a
perfectly cheerful person
maybe the slowest person ever to appear
on cable news
you'll never forget and in case you have
we have the tape
mr lamont's malaysia airlines segment
the one in which he speculated that
maybe the flight
had vanished into a black hole
whether it was hijacking or terrorism or
mechanical failure or pilot error but
what if it was something
fully that we don't really understand a
lot of people have been asking about
that about
black holes and on and on and on they're
also referencing the twilight zone which
has a very similar plot
that's what people are saying i know
it's preposterous but is it preposterous
you think mary
hmm turns out we know this because
we have access to a scientific portal we
call google
that the nearest black hole is about
three thousand
light years away boeing triple sevens
can't yet
fly that far now just in case it seems
like we're being a little cruel to mr
lamont
or the dark dwarf king who employs him
let me just say that there is
love at the bottom of this because mr
lamont combines
almost supernatural slowness
with remarkable self-confidence and if
you don't believe it pull up again on
google
a magazine profile he sat for a few
years ago in which he declared
with total assuredness that the frozen
dessert the rest of us call sorbet is
actually pronounced
sorbette he was adamant about that he's
a news anchor
how can you not love a man like that
howie carr
read that he watches don lemon mr carr
is the undisputed radio king of new
england
he joins us tonight howie were you
surprised by the results of that exam
administered live on air at cnn
you know having watched uh don lemon on
on new year's eve
in those celebrations i think if he had
been presented with silhouettes of
a different type of product say bar room
glasses i think he would have done fine
you know shot glass
cocktail glass rocks glass wine goblet
he would have been okay
i you know i always thought that lawyers
uh learned early on
that uh you never ask questions in court
of a witness unless you know the answer
to them
and uh obviously they didn't do too much
prep work for that
uh that that interview you know they
would just figure you know
if trump uh if trump says he didn't take
the test then they hit him and they say
why won't he take the test what's he
hiding
so he takes the test and then they they
uh they make a support of him anyway
you know i've taken this this test and
uh you know i thought the president
summed it up pretty well i mean it's
you know immediately whether you're uh
whether you're acing it or not you know
if they
they they give you the the face of a
clock with no
no arms on it they say get 10 what's 10
10
and you get it i'd i'd love to hear don
lemon do
do some of those uh tests that they also
give you they're they're the same kind
of test they give you in field sobriety
uh tests
you know so but there's something he
would pass
because and i mean the sincere there's
there's something really endearing
about the fact that he's never
embarrassed this does not
apply to the steroid head buddy on the
screen with him but don lamont
nothing embarrasses him isn't there
something kind of appealing
about that i i guess there is i would
wouldn't you love to see him uh
you know mr lamone can you count
backwards
from uh 100 counting down seven
or or even better here's the one i
really love and i always love to do this
when i have a chance to uh
you know do a police report recite the
alphabet
backwards senator or you know they
they never they never get much beyond
mrn wouldn't you like to see
joe biden take some of these tests
yeah i mean he he did more though than
you than you mentioned he invented two
new job classifications in the last 48
hours
you ever hear of a voter registration
physician
and a pay caregiver and
the the disease that's uh you know put
everybody in lockdown is not covered
nineteen it's coveted nine
it's unbelievable howie carr thank you
so much for coming on tonight
thanks tucker i appreciate it